Fifteen years ago,
I walked into a classroom
as a first-year preschool teacher.
Ambitious and eager to impress,
I created this Excel document
to track the things I thought
mattered most for my students:
letters, numbers, shapes and colors.
Looking back, though,
with what I know now,
I wish I wouldn't have bothered
with Excel or rote memorization.
I wish instead I had leveraged the power
of brain-building interactive play.
For years, we’ve known
that play-based learning
is far superior to rote memorization.
Harvard's Center
on the Developing Child tells us,
as well as countless other institutions,
that play, and especially
the back and forth interactions,
the serve and return,
the alternating comments,
questions, gestures
between children and adults
when they play together,
that's what helps build neural connections
in the child's brain.
And in particular, they build
the brain's prefrontal cortex.
That's the executive
control center of the brain.
The part that manages emotions,
solves problems, makes plans --
all things that children
have to do when they play.
So when we think of it that way,
play is actually hard work.
If learning is like a workout
for the brain,
then play-based learning
is the heavy lifting.
And just as heavy lifting builds muscle,
play-based learning builds
the brain's architecture.
So then where do us as grown-ups come in?
It's those interactions
when a child says something
and a parent or teacher
says something back,
those interactions help the child
to persist, to stick with their plan,
to keep rebuilding the block tower
each time it falls.
So it's the play paired
with the adult interactions.
It's like superfood for the brain.
The research community
in supportive play is so resounding,
I would expect to see children
in nearly every household,
every preschool and kindergarten classroom
playing for most of their waking hours.
But that's far from reality.
We don't see widespread uptake
of play among parents or teachers,
and sometimes we even see resistance.
So what's going on?
What's driving us as parents and teachers
to ignore the overwhelming research
when it comes to play?
After years of teaching preschool,
coaching teachers, coaching parents
and analyzing my own parenting,
I've realized our best intentions
are getting in the way.
We live in a comparison culture,
and we worry that our child
won't be good enough.
Won't be good enough for the soccer team,
won't be ready for kindergarten,
won't be as smart as their classmates.
And we worry that if our child
doesn't measure up,
it will be our fault.
Our hyperfocus on our children
and our students’s success is backfiring.
And it's exacerbated
by two forces I see impacting
the large majority
of parents and teachers.
First, the need
for immediate gratification
and quick results.
And second, our own discomfort with play,
either because we don't have
the time or energy,
or because we just don't know
how to play anymore.
On the topic of immediate gratification,
I think back to that Excel document
I created as a first-year teacher.
That document was
the manifestation of my anxiety,
because often when we feel anxious
or out of control,
we revert back to what we can control.
For parents and teachers,
we often revert to fact-based teaching
because we see pretty immediate results
that affirm our efforts.
Whereas we can't see the connections
in the child's brain
that fire when they finally get
that wobbly block tower to stay standing.
The immediate result of something
like our child learning a new letter,
it gives us this dopamine rush
that then sets off a flywheel effect
because as we see and feel the results
of our work more and more,
we subconsciously begin to prioritize
that type of teaching.
Recently, my staff was coaching
a group of school principals
on the importance of play.
And one of the principals said
that his teachers just weren't on board.
They said their students
are too far behind to play.
And those well-intentioned teachers,
they were equating academic learning
that their students needed
with methods that would show
quick, concrete results.
They felt really proud and accomplished
when they could talk
to the students' parents
and say how many letters
and numbers they learned that month.
Because we as parents and teachers,
we share this universal desire
for our kids to do well.
And we will pour our energy and resources
into making that happen.
And that's showing up
in our spending habits.
Marketers are preying on it as they
advertise the latest and greatest toys,
flashcards, iPad apps
for brain development,
even kits that claim
to teach your baby to read.
Seriously, babies.
And because we worry that our kids
won't measure up, we fall prey to that.
The global market for educational toys
surpassed 68 billion dollars in 2021
and is projected to reach
132 billion by 2028.
But those smart toys,
they're a far cry from the interactive,
playful learning that I was
talking about earlier.
That type of learning, the real gold
standard of early education,
it's not immediate.
It takes time and it doesn't lend itself
to a checklist or an Excel document.
The second force I see
negatively impacting play-based learning
is that we, as grown ups,
parents and teachers,
just don't always like hearing
that play-based learning
might require some of us.
Because that means it will take time,
energy and skills
that we don't think we have.
But not only is it worth our time,
it can be done in really small doses.
So take this simple example of bath time.
If I'm a busy mom who has a few
extra dollars to spend,
I might pop my kiddo into the tub,
remember that buying bath toys has been
on my never-ending mental to-do list
for weeks,
so I whip out my phone
and I use that five minutes
to go over to Amazon
and buy the top-rated bath toys.
And I'm not here to say that those
bath toys are harmful for your child.
They're not.
But you're busy.
So what you do with that five
to 10 minutes, it matters.
And you know what would be
way better than scrolling Amazon
and even better than those bath toys?
Three things that I can almost guarantee
you have in your home.
Measuring cups,
kitchen sponges and you.
Because a couple household materials
dropped into the bathtub,
and this mundane routine
becomes fun and surprisingly
energizing bonding time
for you and your child.
And bonus,
instead of the manufacturer-designed toy
telling your child how to play,
your child's brain
has to do the heavy lifting.
And that's that superfood for the brain.
Now, over the past 10 years
coaching parents,
I have heard over and over again
that parents don't feel good enough
at their job, at parenting.
And there's so much pressure on us,
and sometimes it feels
like we're supposed to innately know
how to get down on the floor
and build our baby's brains.
And over the past few years,
the social media world has exploded
with even more advice
for parents and teachers.
How to affirm children's feelings
but still set clear boundaries.
15 ways to use a cardboard
box in your classroom.
And DIY Halloween costumes that are sure
to win the school costume contest.
And as I rattle those off,
I could just imagine the rolling eyes
from parents and teachers,
and I share that frustration.
Because sometimes all the chatter
only makes us feel
more pressured to get it right.
When it comes to our children's
learning, though,
we don't have to be
the perfect Etsy parent
or the perfect Pinterest teacher.
We have to prioritize interactions
and be OK with them being imperfect.
Because it may seem silly to admit
that we don't feel good
at playing with our kids,
but as adults, it's not always intuitive.
Sure, most of us played
a lot when we were little.
We'd tie the blankets around their neck
and bound around the house
like superheroes.
But as we grew up, that type of play
wasn't encouraged anymore.
And just as with any skill
that we don't use,
we risk losing it.
A couple months ago, my colleague and I,
we were leading a workshop
for parents and teachers.
And we brought materials
like shaving cream
and plastic straws and buttons
and pipe cleaners
and just asked the parents
and teachers to play,
to create.
Everyone froze.
Then, slowly but surely,
people started to create.
And by the end of the session,
their faces were lighting up
as they shared their creations
with the rest of the group.
And it reminded me that as adults,
we have to let go of our expectation
that we get it right.
Because if we opt out of play,
based on what we know
about how important our interactions are
to children's development,
if we opt out of play,
it has major implications
for their brain development.
Now I know that finding the energy
to play with our kids
and students can be hard.
Even in small doses,
it takes our undivided attention.
But it’s so worth it.
Because in all my experience and research,
I haven't found any evidence
that making the homemade cookies
for the school bake sale
matters for your child's
brain development.
I haven't found any evidence that sewing
that winning Halloween costume
means they'll do well in school.
But what does matter
is that the interactions leave space
for your child to learn, to persist,
to play, to experiment.
You have the power to have an enormous
impact on their brain development.
You are helping build the network
of neural connections
that lay the foundation
for all of their future learning.
So this week at bath time,
I hope that you'll put aside
the top-rated toys,
forget that mental
to-do list for a moment,
grab some measuring cups,
some kitchen sponges, and give it a try.
Thank you.
(Applause)